now we've already talked about how the
NHS and business will cope with
coronavirus but it's also of course
putting pressure on other public
services like the police martin hewitt
the chair of the national police chiefs
council is helping to coordinate the
police response to the virus he joins us
now from Westminster thank you for being
on the program today
all the police ready for a crisis like
this well I think the first thing to say
Sofia is that right now police forces
across the UK officers and staff are out
there doing what we do they're in
communities keeping community safe they
are protecting and helping the
vulnerable and they're also dealing with
crime and criminality and we will
continue to do that but as you would
imagine and the word unprecedented has
been used a lot we are facing an
unprecedented situation but we've done
considerable planning we have always
planned to deal with pandemic among
other issues and working with those
other agencies that we will generally
operate with and we have our plans in
place both at a force level across the
UK and as you say I am coordinating now
a national effort to make sure that we
are able to cope with the the issues
that will come and face policing over
the coming weeks and months you say
those plans in place to do with the
pandemic I mean what kind of things
could we see I mean could we see police
for example at supermarkets or helping
assess the vulnerable so the first thing
that we are doing is obviously looking
at our own resourcing this virus is
indiscriminate and it will affect
policing so we've got we've got lots of
work going on individually enforces and
nationally to make sure that we are what
we're describing is orgonite
organizationally distancing so for
example where you have a control center
that answers 999 calls we've split those
into two and three in forces so we've
got distance and we're keeping those
services going and everything we're
doing is about keeping our operations
going we have written out in the last
week - there's over 10,000 special
constables around the country who
volunteer to help policing we are
talking to those special constables -
their employers about how they can
assist as we as we become challenged
around resourcing and as we wouldn't you
would expect we will be prioritizing how
we operate and we already prioritize on
a day to day basis in policing and
those things that represent the most
threats the most harm or risk and we
will continue to do that
the public are being I think are being
very cooperative at the moment and and
as we know people are starting to pay
much more attention to the measures that
are being asked to be to be adhered to
and I would really encourage everybody
to follow the guidance and the advice
that's coming out but what we are also
doing is is wanting people to come
through other channels to policing where
you can reduce the demand on policing
using digital methods using using other
component on 101 and coming in to us
when you need us but we stand ready to
do the role that the police undertakes I
keep people safe protect those
vulnerable people and then also to help
where we can help with the national
effort to defeat the virus you're
talking there a little bit earlier when
your answer about prioritizing I just
want to unpick what exactly that means
because of course the police would be
facing additional pressures because of
coronavirus does that mean that you are
going to have to prioritize and certain
lower level for example crimes may not
end up being investigated I think the
reality is we prioritize all the time
but we are in absolutely unprecedented
situations now our situation now and we
can also see that the the nature of
demand on police and the crime that's
committed will shift as everybody's
lives are changing in the way that they
are they are living their lives that
will shift and we are monitoring that
really closely to understand that shift
but we will have to prioritize as our
resources become more stretched which
they inevitably will we have to
prioritize those things that are the
most likely to cause harm or risk to
people and prioritize so that we are
able to to help the other services
particularly health social care services
local government to assist as we need to
assist in fighting the virus and what
kind of things would be deemed low
priority then well it's I don't really
want I don't think it's about Lowepro to
anything that is causing serious harm to
somebody will obviously be a priority
and policing is always prioritized we
are prioritized at the moment around
violence and serious violence we're
prioritized about where the most
vulnerable are in
to the pond so we are thinking really
carefully and have been thinking about
how we manage that prioritization in
these exceptional circumstances there's
been reporting that more people are more
vulnerable digitally in in this
environment where many people are at
home and we've been doing work through
our normal channels to put information
out to people about how they can prevent
themselves becoming vulnerable you will
have seen information that's coming out
from government coming out from the
National cybercrime Center so it's about
getting information out to people so
that they can protect themselves and
keep themselves safe and then us using
our resources as they inevitably become
stretched to do what we need to do
around those things that require require
a stronger police presence and require
us to protect people the the message
that I've been really struck from doing
this program talking to a range of
different guess is how important social
distancing is and how that is the one
thing that people believe could turn the
tide as the Prime Minister put on the
virus do you see if there are stricter
social distancing measures put in place
in the coming weeks that the police
could have a role to play in ensuring
some of these businesses stay shut
insuring pubs close and insuring people
perhaps don't go out unnecessarily so I
think the first point to make is that
the vast majority of of pubs clubs
businesses have been entirely compliant
with the messaging that came out on on
Friday and I think that's really
positive and and I will hope that that
would would carry on
of course as we move forward if there
are issues with people ignoring the
advice and this this is advice that is
saving people's lives
that's how serious it is if people are
ignoring that advice then clearly we
will play our part there are other
licensing authorities that will have a
role to play but of course the police
will play its part and when you talk
about people if we end up with with in
on the streets then I think the really
important point to make is we will carry
on doing our policing role and we will
carry on doing our policing role in the
way that we police in the in the UK
which is that traditional role of being
in communities policing with consent and
we will be doing whatever we do in
support of health officials this is a
health crisis
first and foremost and the really
important point is that
stop the level of transmission getting
higher and higher and where there is a
role for the police to play in that we
will play that role and obviously what I
will be doing is making sure that we are
able to do that across the UK and
equally importantly keeping our staff
safe because our officers and staff will
be out there in communities policing and
assisting with this effort and we've got
to do everything that we can do to keep
our staff safe because they are as
vulnerable as anybody else and clearly
they are as worried about their families
and their loved ones as everybody else
is of course I should say police staff
not completely invulnerable to
coronavirus which could put pressure on
numbers do you see a situation where you
could potentially working together with
the army so there's a range weak we
always have plans to be able to work
with not just the military with build
all sorts of other agencies that can
assist us we've put plans in place in
every force to manage how we get how we
survive and how we continue to deliver
our service if we have reduced numbers
particularly in specialist areas what my
teams are doing at the centre is we are
able as we already do for other big
issues we are able to move resources
around the country to support areas that
are particularly under pressure and I'm
getting daily reporting to understand
precisely where we are in terms of the
numbers of our officers and staff that
are unable to work either because
they're sick or they're self isolating
we will work with all parts of
government and we will provide we will
provide support and others will
undoubtedly provide support to us we
have well tested methods of working with
the military but I kind of restate the
point we are going to be capable of
policing in the way that we have policed
of course we will be stretched that's
why I ask people to think about placing
demands on our service but we are locked
in at a local level with all the other
emergency services and agencies that you
would expect and I'm locked in at a
national level so that we are able to
make the best use of our resources not
only to do our day job in policing but
also to support this extraordinary
national effort to to prevent the spread
of the virus
Martin Hewitt's thank you very much for
being on the program today thank you